[Musica]
cazzo è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi
siamo in un nuovo blog ragazzo ci sia un
silenzio della madonna non so perché sto
registrando sto blog anche ad alta voce
mi chiama se sto zitto non sento un
cazzo inquietantissimo sono parti tutti
con chi ragazzi come al solito dire di
cominciare collaborante della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
alessandra che ha fatto che sto studenti
la patria mica un capo launch ai ragazzi
gli ormai non so neanche come
descrivereste questo modello sono le
dipinti è una cosa pazzesca è tra
l'altro al contempo ciottolo slider che
mai da anni avviene la corporazione
affanculo
comunque per quanto riguarda le news
ragazzino nero tantissime parole le
poche che ciò penso che vi piaceranno da
morire
anche perché sono momenti che aspettate
da secoli credo dapprima i nostri
ragazzi il presidente sta sta uscendo
outlast il dlc uscirà il 7 maggio
no il 6 maggio scusate però dato che
devo registrare di tavolo uscirai lidl 7
attratto da sole non dormite la notte
perché non vedete l'ora di farvi
prendere gli infarti e nonna che vi
giuro mi faccio finire come lui dettagli
i capelli di notte quando non me ne
accorgete e comunque questa l'ho detta
siete liberi di desiderare che arrivi il
7 per mia sfortuna comunque
fortunatamente ci sono anche nelle
notizie buone per me almeno quelle se
tutto va bene ragazzi il 15 di maggio
mi pare che fosse 15 poi non mi ricordo
bene adesso vorrei farmi fail dovrebbe
uscire in verbis virtus ragazzi che uno
dei giochi più belli che abbia mai
giocato non lo avevo registrato tipo in
anno fa una la demo quella che era
uscita e gioco completo ragazzi uscirà
verso il 15 di maggio normale genere non
vorrei sbagliare comunque lo farò di
sicuro e quindi ragazzi le news sono
finita anche se mi sembra strano perché
la volta in cui ci ho messo di meno
cazzo al record quindi dire che possiamo
passare al fa vi risponde anno cazzo di
un cartoccio di pacchi minchia misto
rincoglionendo
volevo passarla liscia chiami stava
ammazza e ancora sporco di latte a terra
ma facciamo finta di niente come se non
fosse successo con 44 oggi perché perché
sono troppo buono ma praticamente
ragazzi narro 4 più piccoli perché tira
ci sono 12 miliardi di platì enormi che
prima inter di lo sa che hai pensato ma
la prevendita deciso di aprire quelli
più piccoli ragazzi perché se continuo
ad aprile quelli grossi 9 per i venti
non finisco più a proseguire i piccoli
lascio sempre da parte quindi i neutroni
più ma ne apro un po tutti
vabbè avete capito che assiste i ragazzi
mi sa che ci hanno messo qualcosa in
quel latte non è normale concrete come
questa con quest'apertura professional i
rei chemical questo è questa io non so
se a prendermele in camera probabilmente
si è descritto pa vj unico scritto
migliori madonna ragazzo che sherlock
holmes cazzo
[Musica]
io dico che non è normale ragazzo ho il
mio dirigibile minchia che la festa è
bellissimo io passano le giornate a
farmi così belli nostra tendesse moro
ragazzi allora la verità è che mi
diverto con poco ragazzi ormai mi sembra
la cosa ci ha preso gente capito tutti
tra l'altro che cazzo è stata perché
brusco pacco che vendo quando mi inviati
flexi di giornali cazzo vanto lo amo e
desideri tutti svegli la mattina dice
cazzo mi servono dei pezzi di giornali
bellissimo gr grazie che hanno giuro
siete fantastici premi che devo capire
che cazzo ci dovrebbe essere sotto sta
cosa è una ok adesso ho capito perché vi
voglio bene ragazzi vorrei ringraziare
di cuore che mi ha inviato questo palco
perché giura mi ha aggiustato la
giornata in una maniera che non potete
capire ai ragazzi di importante prendere
le cose con filosofia
ecco e corro sconto del 50 per cento
marco ragazzi anche se la vedo un po
difficile mettere a posto dopo tutto sto
casino ma chi se ne frega eccolo qui
maledizioni lo aspettavo da troppo tempo
sponge erano secoli che bramava sto
pupazzo maledizione grazie mille
ai ragazzi da va beh questo non poteva
ma parte dalla nu dell'ina solita grazie
mille c'è anche il manuale della nutella
non pensavo esistesse sta roba giuro io
giuro non so che cos'è questo ma è
inquietante da morire
[Musica]
e come ultima cosa ragazzi abbiamo una
band no questa cosa e morbidissimo sto
coso no ragazzi è fantastico a ciascun
tasto sinistro ammazzando dopo questo
non riuscirò mai più di casa e quindi
ragazzi detto questo vi ringrazio per i
fatti perché sono splendidi come al
solito a parte la carta ma la piccola si
rimedia e quindi noi che possiamo
passare al fa vi risponde ma vi risponde
falliti ha mai capitato di rifare il
video perché nel finale è accaduto il
telecomando
se un mito mi fai divertire troppo a dir
la verità ragazzi quando mi succede che
mi cade il telecomando per far che mi
succede che mi cade il telecomando
rifaccio la scena in cui mi lancio al
telecomando mi rifaccio tutto il video
ci mancherebbe dove la per nulla poiché
parte salvato un pezzo di video dove mi
lancia il telecomando più volte
aspettate che lo cerco essere severi si
è distinto io mi ci vediamo al prossimo
video capitana senza senza da vari siti
scriveteli ci vediamo il prossimo video
per ragazzi ma che cazzo se non siete
crisi destinazioni ci mettiamo il
prossimo video bella la gara va beh se
lo lancio sul nettuno roberto sandulli
sai fare come steve favola ama stop
ma risponde fa v6 fare un trucco di
magia signore dice tanto meno ci
prendiamo un mazzo di coach e di forme
del numero di magia sensazionale
condividiamo le carte mentana così
perfetto che dividiamo facciamo vedere
che sono brani con le carte perfetto
anche se non serve un cazzo facciamo per
far vedere che sono qui torniamo mazzo
di carte così facciamo vedere che c'è un
bel mazzo di carte e poi diciamo magico
gamer spaventano di fitto lo standard lo
avevo già detto secoli fa ma non importa
comunque vi hanno ridipinto la standard
e chiaro che adesso arancione prima era
gialla è tratto ragazzi volevo farmi
notare che tipo si avvicina è cosa
vicino lui cambia lo sfondo non so
perché guardate il muro ed è visto tu
sei un cazzo di marco comunque ragazzi
dell'ultimo blog mi sono dimenticato
della fabi domanda e tipo mi avete
minacciato di morte in una maniera
incredibile è quindi per concludere
linee di passare ad affari domanda e
volevo chiedervi ragazzi secondo me
quello è stato lo spavento più bello che
abbia mai preso ma sai da ragazzi potete
rispondermi qui sotto nei commenti se il
video è piaciuto lasciato argomento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
ogni video tratta nella descrizione
sanseveresi iscrivetevi lì ci vediamo al
prossimo video verrà ragazzi